I got I was gonna I gotta send you guys
do you see the [ __ ] Trump the most
recent rally I don't care how you feel
about Trump the guy's funniest [ __ ] yeah
hilarious cannot deny I said that I said
well draw my own little rocket man was
the funny thing I've ever heard in my
life so there lay the trumpeting let's
see bro look at this I reap Oh stood it
all you did holy [ __ ] this thing it's on
my Twitter he's so ridiculous it's it
this had me [ __ ] howling last night I
woke them up
I woke mark and Alex up in the Airbnb
just to watch this video go down go down
go down this one right here
yes go to the beginning go to the winner
he's talking about Elizabeth Warren
remember when she had that video you see
her beer deal where she said oh darling
I've seen that too darling it's about
her husband darling it's great to see
you what are you doing here it's like
that's her husband's supposed to be
living in the house turn this over can I
get a beer let's get up here you know
she wants to be one of the group hey
let's get a beer did you ever see such a
phony disgusting he was hard in the
paint man bro he called Buddha Judge
Alfred Newman yeah hilarious hilarious
the Mad Magazine guy that impeachment
stuff just feels like it's like such a
waste of time and that's why he's doing
this that's what he keeps up this
because this is offensive his super
powers you say oh yeah I go on the
offensive yeah the thing about him is
that he never is a and it's actually a
brilliant strategy I never realized it
but like he never defends himself no no
he just attacks and the brilliant thing
about it is no max nothing just people
who listen anybody listen to politics
State they've hacked like [ __ ]
children like we're discussing politics
without putting our personal opinion on
politics we're just talking yeah Brian
Collins not here to destroy this podcast
with yeah he well he ruins almost every
one of these shows by the way that a
million times ever just rule was this
show but you know say so it's like what
he does is an interesting strategy right
somebody says something about him yeah
he's been in
pseudo politics but also entertaining in
10 years he knows like you said earlier
everybody's a phony piece of [ __ ] yeah
so when she when the Biden say the
Ukraine thing with him he's like are you
talking about me he's gonna go hard so
and all these people got dirt I was I
forget exactly who said it but politics
is a mudslinging contest right but he's
made a mud yeah everybody else wearing
white he's made of mud you know what's
brilliant he does the exact same thing
that like we've talked about this before
about he does the same thing that clever
people in comedy or entertainment to
when somebody attacks us instead of us
attacking them I let my fans go after
them so I just walk away so what he does
what's smart is when someone goes Trump
XYZ he doesn't comment on it his [ __ ]
fan base they do all the Fox News does
all of his work for him that he didn't
even ask him to do they just go do it
it's weird it's like when somebody says
Andrew Schultz sucks if you just retweet
that watch what happens to that guy from
your fans your fan you don't need to do
eat them
yeah you don't need it so he liked
everything I never retweet because I
don't want them to think I saw it give
the power to the people
Trump smart enough to just go watch this
watch what [ __ ] Hills oh yeah he does
he'll separate he doesn't evil yes he
picks him back to how powerful they are
exactly if you have no power
he's not talking about now unless he can
use what you said to leverage right
right so like it's just interesting
whoever bubbles up is like somebody
who's uh who's like a pretty good front
runner etc he'll start to take shots at
goes on whenever and then these people
these like politicians most these
politicians are coddled they're not like
[ __ ] real men you know what I mean
they're like they're guys who have like
rich [ __ ] dads and that kind of [ __ ]
they never had ball no one wrote that um
a lot of room she's [ __ ] life he got
into Yale probably because of some
nepotism [ __ ] and then also in you're on
stage and this Google idea with the
footlight yeah destroying orange fades
or white I
the [ __ ] downs roasting the [ __ ] out
of you dude and if they just crumble
have you ever been like wait when you're
in the line of fire with someone who
knows how to roast it's over it gets
unless you got it it's over
you see we've seen you see it firsthand
it's ugly as [ __ ] when he does the
Democratic [ __ ] I can't wait I can't
wait well he like lines up the Democrats
it's all firing squad myself man dude I
can't wait I want but here's the thing
is I think he just I think we all know
what he knows is that he didn't [ __ ]
he didn't want to be president he was
surprised that he won president he just
wanted to be able to talk [ __ ] and run
all the way up the flagpole and when he
got up there he was like yeah guess I'm
the best and I that solidified him being
like I am the best ego he's gotta have
an ego right now but now it's final T I
think he thought I do for using in the
[ __ ] out B'nai psyche oh you don't think
I can do it channel D he wants to do it
yeah if they would have went oh no you
stay man he be like god [ __ ] I'm out
but now I've only goes dude you're the
worst president ever he's like oh really
I'm gonna be miserable I'm stay another
for watch he's gonna make he's gonna
he's gonna make some law where he can go
three terms it'll just sit the [ __ ] up
the same dude he did that's on the tweak
he said that he goes he goes 20 20 20 20
for 20 28 goes I'm just kidding these
stupid people MSNBC they're gonna act
like it's real I'm just kidding maybe
I'm not though maybe we go for it man
but you can't even admit he's funny
because in these [ __ ] idiots start
cold all you agree with every one of his
policies this I don't know I don't know
agree with every comic but I can say
they're funny yeah there's a lot of
comics that are hilarious it's just the
ID idea now is people are afraid to be
even associated with them because they
think that you're you you are backing up
what he sees radioactive so if you say
anything good about a radioactive
substance you must be radioactive people
right there and then once they just make
you radioactive nobody wants to talk but
when we say this by the way we're
referring to an extremely small percent
of the population the more the talk to
that more people I taught us when you
travel media yes
the more people you talk to in this
[ __ ] country they have they have
enough sensibility to know yeah that
we're talking about this thing in
comedic light and they know what you
know is their [ __ ] they joke about
the same [ __ ] they could you see with
this [ __ ] there's
normal Democrat in the middle of this
country would say the same thing they go
this [ __ ] was hilarious II this [ __ ]
bozo Jeff yeah because they're they have
sensibility but we're talking about the
mind the minority of social media that
loses their mind over nothingness right
they're very small we see them as large
because they're in our face every day
and we're in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
business but dude you go to most of the
country they get it they get it a lot
more because they deal with it
differently we were just absorbed by
Twitter we're like we're we have to live
inside of this [ __ ] this this this
echo chamber sphere of like you're
either on this side now you're on this
side and if you're one of those same
jealous of those commands who don't deal
with it there's a few community you
don't deal at all deal with why I'm or
social media that the whole social world
yeah do you know what it is whew there's
a few not a lot even burr is on [ __ ]
Instagram now it's like some of those
guys avoided it forever
and you got to do it finally got in you
kind of you kind of have part of it it's
like it's honestly it's no different
than any sport it's like as the
supportive all's you need to learn more
things like what happened in MMA all of
a sudden these wrestlers start to come
in and people like oh [ __ ] I better
learn how to gotta get on the ground oh
yeah I do that wrestling I think it's
weird when you hear like some comms go
I'm not gonna do the [ __ ] the
Instagram human like that's a waste of
time man like I just do it on the stage
like now here you don't want to be a
couple or they go well the only reason
he sells take because he is a successful
comedy podcast like no I I get it dude
that's the game like you don't have it
when everyone came of all that he says
do you don't want to be assumed that he
empathizes they're immediately followed
by a jealous nonsense statement that
doesn't mean anything the only reason
that Schultz gets the only reason that
shop
the only reason statements are cop-outs
for their insecurities of jealousy of
whatever that's where they are in the in
the game but the reality of the matter
is like as the game changes you need to
do what it takes to succeed within it
right and if you want to play basketball
you need to have a trainer that comes
with you all year round yeah LeBron pays
its trainer all year round and the elite
MBA players do that this is a
requirement for the new NBA back in the
day you could work Congress right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
Oh [ __ ] business